Steve for the next few sessions we're
going to be talking about second Isaiah
which is a part of the larger Book of
Isaiah itself so maybe the best way to
begin to think about second Isaiah is to
look at the whole book and to try to
characterize it in some way what is
special and different about this book
the first thing that always strikes me
when I'm looking at Isaiah is simply the
little physical length of the book it's
longer in terms of chapters than any
other biblical book with the possible
exception of the Book of Psalms why do
you think it has this particular
character yeah it's very very it's a
very neat book and a book that obviously
has had a tremendous impact if you look
at the lectionary prophecies of Isaiah
occur as often as all the other
prophetic books combined
if you look at just the history of
interpretation the use of Qumran with
the Dead Sea Scrolls the east and the
New Testament it was one of the favorite
books the the depth and the power of
this book is incredible as to the length
just the the physical length is
something but the the expanse of time of
history that is covered is to me
remarkable we're not talking about the
same sort of situation as say a letter
of Paul to the Romans or even a gospel
written into a matthew community or to a
mark community where you've got one
fixed audience at a particular time but
you're really talking about hundreds of
years the initial Isaiah that was
working in in Jerusalem it's way back in
the 8th century and by the time you get
to some of this material in chapters 40
to 55 that scholars have traditionally
called
second Isaiah your way up hundreds of
years later after the Exile of 586 into
the rise of the Persian king Cyrus
around 540
there's many audiences in an ongoing
engagement with this powerful Word of
God over decades even centuries that's
represented in this book so it's really
a very special book and probably quite
different from other prophetic books
that people read or even any other book
in the Bible as a whole that people
might read so it's that's a fascinating
book just from the get-go well the fact
that it was created over a long period
of time and seems to have involved a
number of audiences and undoubtedly a
number of different writers would that
be related then to the fact that it also
has a fairly wide range of literary
forms in the book it's not an easy book
to read for that reason because the the
different kinds of Oracle's that appear
the shaping of the book varies so
quickly and so often is that do you
think related to this overall
compositional history that the book
seems to have had yeah the book is
remarkable for their variety of material
in it I think to people who are reading
it for the first time it can be somewhat
challenging it can be challenging even
if you're used to reading other
prophetic books you think of prophets
like Amos or Hosea they're used to
delivering channeling a divine Word of
God to it to a target audience but in
Isaiah you've got a Word of God that is
almost a force a physical force moving
through history well beyond just this
initial figure of prophet Isaiah of
Jerusalem of the eighth century so to to
try to read through the book and to
understand the movement of this physical
force of God's Word and its impact time
and time again in human lives is it's
very very engaging the the poetry of the
book is is also incredibly deep and rich
and I think as we go through some of
these sections of the
we'll want to look at some of this
beautiful poetry that's so inspiring and
engaging there's also a great variety of
poetry in the book the Oracles of Isaiah
that seem mostly to be concentrated in
the first part of the book often are
very enigmatic it's one of those
difficult kinds of scripture to read
because it doesn't seem to be linear in
any way the Oracle's don't seem to have
any obvious form of arrangement they
don't fit any pattern they seem to drift
from one thing to another and often the
articles themselves eventually almost
dissolve at the end just when you're
looking for some kind of a climactic
statement the Oracle's almost
disintegrate into nothingness the ends
that are often totally obscure which in
a way encourages the interpretation of
these things they remain so difficult
that they almost demand some kind of
interpretation in order to know
something about them it seems to me that
probably also here is involved a
different notion of what prophecy is in
the Isiah tradition and that in order to
understand that you really have to
understand what prophecy was in ancient
Israel and how it was understood
somewhat later words about that I think
that would be actually very helpful
let me yeah let me let me simply
characterize prophecy generally first
and then indicate how the Isaiah
prophesies are somewhat different in the
way they operate and in the assumptions
behind them prophecy just generically
occurred in ancient Israel when
individuals felt themselves possessed by
the Spirit of God and when that happened
God spoke through the individual and the
assumption of the Society and the
prophets themselves was that the
recked word of god was coming through
the individual without respect to what
the words might be but the prophet's job
was simply to transmit those words
mostly they were fairly clear in
contrast to what we know say about Greek
prophecy of the sub of the the Oracle at
Delphi for example which specialized in
being obscure whereas in ancient Israel
as much as we can tell the prophecies
were mostly intelligible and they were
often directed to a specific situation
in the life of the people so when God
wanted to communicate with people there
would be this direct communication that
spoke to a particular situation they
also would speak about the future
because often what was true in the
present and decisions that people made
about the communication between God and
Israel that would determine what future
events might take place so these
prophecies often speak both of present
and future both together one or the
other there was a fair amount of variety
there once the prophecies were fulfilled
often people then simply recorded them
and their fulfillment and archived them
and they come into our text that doesn't
seem to have happened with the Isaiah
tradition and in that sense the Isaiah
tradition is somewhat different Isaiah
seems to have thought it was a position
accepted by the Prophet himself the
original prophet but also by his
disciples who are explicitly mentioned
in chapter 8 verse 16 there's a
reference there to the disciples having
custody of the auricles and lying behind
this seems to be the notion that a true
prophecy once given is capable of being
fulfilled over and over again and it was
not exhausted in a single fulfillment
and therefore the tradition assumed and
the disciples assumed and the Prophet
himself assumed
that one could continue to interpret
these prophecies yeah I think that that
that whole notion is such a powerful
insight and it was largely lost in
modern scholarship if you pick up most
the commentaries or most study Bibles
they will try to take Isaiah and divide
it into parts and to locate each part in
one specific timeframe one specific
audience one specific author and
captured by the tale in that way like
most other biblical books are treated
and that's really where we get this
language of second Isaiah in the first
place
modern scholarship discerned that Isaiah
40 chapters 40 to 55 was at the product
of a prophet in the Exile and it was
directed to a specific exilic audience
that had been moved way over to the
other side of the Fertile Crescent after
Babylonia destroyed Jerusalem in 586 and
the whole book of Isaiah was partitioned
off so that this middle section second
Isaiah was just about that one situation
but I think now as scholars have
continued to work on this book it it
appears far different than that you've
got this prophetic word in the initial
chapters that keeps on going with this
power and this vitality in this cutting
edge and the material in chapters 40
following second Isaiah is clearly in
conversation with that it's moving
forward with that
with that word in a new way so I think
we have to begin talking about second
Isaiah differently than many modern
contemporary scholars do yes what seems
to have happened was that the Isaiah
disciples and the Isaiah tradition later
on continues this process of
interpretation which was more or less
authorized by the Prophet himself and we
see the process of reinterpretation or
continued interpretation of the
fulfilled Oracle's within the work of
the earliest layers of the work of
Isaiah Jerusalem do you think about that
we could just maybe look
chapter let's look at a seven and eight
and just an example quick example of
this we're going to see a lot of those
but certainly the one of the easy places
to see it is in the famous article about
a manual that occurs in chapter 7 verse
14 the setting is a response to a crisis
that occurred in 735 32 where there was
an effort by the northern kingdom of
ephraim to recapture jerusalem and to
end the control of the Davidic dynasty
there in response to that to guarantee
an Oracle of the salvation of the city
Isaiah gave a sign to the king ahaz and
the assign was this famous birth of the
child a young woman is now pregnant and
is about to bear a son and shall name
him Emmanuel so Emmanuel is in Hebrew
God is with us and in the context of
that event this was a positive Oracle
for the King and for the city as a whole
but it occurs again in invert a chapter
8 verse 8 the disbelief of the King
calls forth a future judgment and the
future judgment Isaiah clearly tells us
is going to be the coming of the
Assyrian army and the army is going to
invade and play siege to the city this
is a reference to an event that occurred
in 701 so almost 30 years later
this article is seem to be fulfilled
Emmanuel shows up again in verse 8 and
it is said that the Assyrians are going
to sweep into Judah like a flood poring
over it will reach up to the neck and
its outspread wings will fill the
breadth of your land wholly Emmanuel the
coming of God now in this situation is
an act of judgment not of promise so
this kind of alternation between
judgment and promise referring to the
same original prophecy is an example of
the way in which the tradition moved I
mean originally Emanuel was a child who
this this separate crisis of this
coalition from the north would be over
by the time he's old he's old encouraged
and honey now over you know 35 years
later Emanuel is being applied to a
whole new crisis it's not this and a
whole new thing it's now the city and
it's the city that has this message that
God is with us but whereas before it was
good news now it is not good news and
they're just we're gonna see a lot of
that and the material that we're going
to look at next in the next unit in 10
through 12 yes I think that's that's
exactly right this these initial
prophecies keep going with with this
vitality and life and in some ways they
become more clear as the community
eventually the second Isaiah community
reflects on them initially it's just a
child who has a special name but by
verse 8 of chapter 8 this Emmanuel seems
to be somebody who has a land the
Assyrians are going to fill up the
breadth of your land Oh a manual that
off that often awfully much sounds like
Emmanuel is a king who's presiding over
a land it gets to look more like a
messianic figure at least to some people
at this point and then just a few verses
later at the end of chapter 10 you get
the the term at least in Hebrew Emmanuel
again and many English translations it
just says God is with us but in Hebrew
emanuelle so same it's the same third
reinterpretation or a third impact of an
initial prophecy that just can't be tied
down to its initial dating in 735 and
that will become the pattern that we're
going to see in the rest of the material